this month we are celebrating the 32nd
anniversary of the americans with
disabilities act but with the lifting of
covert precautions many people with
disabilities as well as those facing
serious illness feel forgotten about 7
million americans have compromised
immune systems which puts them at a
higher risk for severe covet and
possibly even death earlier this year
the cdc director said that among
vaccinated people it's mostly those with
comorbidities who are dying from the
virus but many in the disability
community were outraged by that
statement feeling it devalued their
lives
they began sharing their stories using
the hashtag my disabled life is worthy
we spoke with three people with
disabilities about their experiences
we've faced mass death
in the disabled community as a result of
kovid
my name is ola o.j woomy
and i'm a disability rights activist in
the washington dc metropolitan area
since i was 9 years old i have been
disabled i was diagnosed with a rare
heart condition i needed to be put on
the organ transplant waiting list for a
heart and kidney a few years after my
transplants i was diagnosed with a rare
form of post-transplant cancer
as a disabled person getting covered
could be a death sentence this is
something that i take every night i live
with chronic migraine which means that i
get 15 or more migraine attacks a month
i'm currently living at a migraine every
single day my condition is an invisible
disability because you can't see it but
that's the thing that disabled doesn't
have a look anyone can be disabled here
we go my name is carm rose fialo my
pronouns are she her i'm a queer
disabled latina and i am a disability
advocate to the pandemic with mask
mandates being lifted in nearly every
state
the mass mandates had been lifted on
airplanes and i didn't realize like how
soon it was effective and i was flying
home the next day and i got on
an airplane and i was shocked by how
many people weren't wearing masks i'm
already disabled and even though i'm
vaccinated and boosted and more likely
to get mild covered i still have an
equal chance of getting long covet and
for me to add chronic fatigue and all
those symptoms on top of what i'm
already dealing with it would just be
extremely detrimental and debilitating i
think it's hard to process
what's actually happening right now
which is
most people are going to get covered the
way that that falls on my ears is
that
we
should just expect
that
we might get severely ill and die
that it's inevitable
my name is christine mitchell and i have
marfan syndrome which is a connective
tissue disorder my anxiety around
contracting covid is that i am at high
risk if i got it even when i've had the
flu it has impacted me
pretty severely the overwhelming number
of deaths over 75 percent occurred in
people who had at least four
comorbidities so really these are people
who were unwell to begin with to hear
that
that
the death of someone like me was
considered encouraging
news
i think was also very painful the way to
make people with disabilities not feel
excluded is to give them positions of
power i would like to see actual people
with disabilities actual doctors and
professionals with disabilities leading
the cdc's effort it's time for america
to get back to work and fill our great
downtowns again with people people
working from home can feel safe and
begin to return to their offices
i definitely feel
like disabled and immunocompromised
people are being forgotten
as we
do this return to normal people should
have the choice and the flexibility to
work from home and
i understand and can appreciate that you
know working in person working with your
team is really beneficial but i think
that we just need to be flexible with
people and give people the choice i
think
at an individual level
things like
mask mandates things like vaccination
things like
access to testing
remain very important
the thing about being disabled
is that people feel that it can never
happen to them
but kovit has proven
that it can make you disabled it is a
mass disabling event that has created
disabilities for thousands of people
you can prevent yourself
and others from becoming disabled by
simply wearing a mask